hallo zusammen schönen guten Tag
willkommen zu ZDF heute live der König
ist da royaler Besuch in Deutschland der
britische König Charles III ist kurz vor
zwei am Flughafen in Berlin gelandet
hier sehen wir jetzt die Bilder
ja hier sehen wir König Charles und
seine Queen concert Camilla in türkis
Salutschüsse gab's zur Begrüßung 2 €
Fighter haben das begleitet dann schnell
runter die Treppe auf den roten Teppich
und hier die offizielle Begrüßung am
Flughafen mit Blümchen und dann ging es
auch relativ zügig ähm ins Auto und
mittlerweile sind Charles und Camilla
auf dem Weg
ans Brandenburger Tor
ja da wollen wir jetzt auch hinschauen
das ist ein royales Ereignis dass wir in
der kommenden Stunde begleiten wollen
dazu laden wir euch herzlich ein Fragen
und Kommentare gerne in die Chats
schreiben oder an die E-Mail-Adresse
schicken die ihr jetzt eingeblendet seht
hier sehen wir auch schon am
Brandenburger Tor oder durch die Stadt
an diesen Fanfaren
Zug wir sprechen mit unserer ZDF
königshaus-expertin Julia Melcher mit
unserer London Korrespondentin Hilke
Petersen die den Besuch des Königs
begleitet und jetzt erstmal wie gesagt
mit unserem Reporter in Berlin Nils
Schneider am Brandenburger Tor
[Musik]
hallo Nils grüße Euch gerade sehr genau
ja ähm es gibt bei solchen
Staatsbesuchen Nils ja einen ein sehr
strenges Protokoll und danach werden der
König und seine Frau im gleich am
Brandenburger Tor Vorfahren wir empfängt
Berlin das Königspaar eher egal oder
große Aufregung
ja Entschuldigung für das eben es ist
ein bisschen laut hier gerade weil das
Wachbataillon gerade aufzieht die
sozusagen die Ehrenformation wählen und
nachher die Nationalhymnen spielen also
Berlin empfängt den König und die
Königin ich sag mal mit einer sehr
großen Ehre sie werden nämlich hier am
Brandenburger Tor empfangen das ist das
erste Mal ist ein Staatskasse sozusagen
hier die militärischen Ehren bekommt
ansonsten was die Zuschauer anbelangt
hier auf dem Platz dürfen 1500
charlustige stehen während des Besuches
und ich würde mal sagen momentan sind es
vielleicht ja die Hälfte 750 das kann
daran liegen dass die Besucher sich
teilweise vorher anmelden mussten sie
müssen durch die Sicherheitsschleuse und
werden immer nur so in kleinen zehn
Zwanziger Stärken auf dem Platz gelassen
aber muss schon sagen so eine
Begeisterung wie es bei der Queen gab
oder wie bei Kate und William als die
haben diese Begeisterung ist noch nicht
da aber Berlin empfängt den König und
die Königin schon ich sag mal sehr
pompös
wunderbar vielen Dank schon mal für den
richtigen Begriff Wachbataillon arbeiten
jetzt noch eine Frage wie hat sich die
Hauptstadt denn insgesamt auf diesem
Besuch vorbereitet
kurz ein paar Zahlen dazu sind heute
allein 900 Polizisten im Einsatz morgen
und übermorgen werden es sogar 1.100
sein und es wurde auch Verstärkung aus
anderen Bundesländern angefangen sind
zum Beispiel 20
sprengstoffspürhunde aus anderen
Bundesländern nach Berlin gekommen um
sozusagen zu unterstützen so viele Hunde
die das können gibt's in Berlin einfach
nicht ansonsten muss man sagen ist die
Berliner Polizei was Staatsbesuche
ambulant einfach super professionell
also mit einer Präzision führen Sie die
Kolonnen die verkehrsgeladen oder die
durch die Stadt das sind teilweise die
Straßen immer nur ein zwei Minuten
gesperrt das geht unglaublich präzise
also da ist die Berliner Polizei
wirklich wirklich geschult und kriegt
das immer super hin ansonsten sind
natürlich alle Orte die der König und
die Königin besuchen weitere mich
abgesperrt jeder der dahinten will und
und eine Akkreditierung oder brauchen
eine Akkreditierung musste sich vorher
sicherheitstracks unterziehen das
Bundeskriminalamt hat das alles im
Hintergrund gemacht und das musste man
auch schon zwei Wochen vorher anmelden
wenn man so eine gewissen Art hin wollte
oder hin will von daher muss man da
schon einige sicherheitstext über sich
ergehen lassen alles klar also für die
Berliner Sicherheitskräfte fast Business
Essen vielen Dank Nils Schneider
ja wir warten auf die Ankunft von König
Charles und Camilla am Brandenburger Tor
wo er gleich von Bundespräsident
Steinmeier und mit militärischen
ehrenempfang wird seine erste
Auslandsreise als König Andreas Stamm
hatte Infos
ein Monarch geht auf Reisen und die
Dinge laufen nicht immer nach Plan
Frankreich sollte es werden für die
erste Auslandsreise Charles des dritten
doch die anhaltenden Proteste gegen die
Rentenreform verhindern dass ein
74-jähriger seinen Job machen kann die
Reise verschoben und Deutschland dass
der König eigentlich von Paris aus
ansteuern wollte mit so zum Reiseziel
Nummer 1
königliche Familie hat deutsche Wurzeln
und darüber hat Charles auch bei seinem
letzten Besuch in Deutschland 2020 oft
gesprochen er spricht gerne darüber und
er wird seine erste Ansprache nach der
Ankunft halb auf Englisch halb auf
Deutsch halten
der eigentliche Zweck des halbierten
Trips bleibt Verben für bessere Zeiten
nach der Unzeit des brexit-prozesses im
Auftrag der Politik
als König reist du dorthin wo ich die
Regierung hinschickt aber ähnlich wie
bei einem US-Präsidenten ist das Ziel
der ersten Reise von großer
diplomatischer Bedeutung von Seiten der
Regierung wird von Charles erwartet dass
er dabei hilft die Beziehungen mit
Europa wieder aufzubauen und zu
verbessern
in Deutschland ähnelt dem was Charles
schon in der Vergangenheit bestaunen
durfte Berlin und die hohe Politik doch
nun eben als König inklusive Staatsbank
kennt den 21 Schuss salut am Flughafen
hören selbst hohe Staatsgäste nur selten
soll nach dem Beginn eines neuen
Kapitels zwischen beiden Ländern klingen
hört man aus dem Präsident
[Musik]
Präsident Steinmeier trägt richtig dick
auf vieles von dem was Charles macht mit
einem Premiere für einen Monarchen zum
ersten Mal mit allen Ehrenamt
Brandenburger Tor empfangen zu werden im
Bundestag zu sprechen als König er wird
mit sehr großen Respekt behandelt ein
großer Moment für ihn
das Königspaar wird eine
Flüchtlingsunterkunft in der Hauptstadt
besuchen einen Wochenmarkt
Umweltschutzprojekte nach zwei Tagen
Berlin folgt eine Stippvisite in
Deutschlands vielleicht britischster
Stadt Hamburg alte Bekannte für seinen
bundestagsauftritt morgen könnte Charles
glatt seine prinzenrede vom Besuch 2020
wiederverwenden wir werden immer Freunde
Partner und Verbündete sein genau das
soll die Visite nach allem was der
brexit kaputt gemacht hat unterstreichen
wenn ein alter Bekannter seine 29
offiziellen Deutschlandbesuch absolviert
nun als König Charles der dritte
jedoch ist der König nicht am
Brandenburger Tor angekommen dafür steht
aber unsere zdf-korrespondentin Helke
Petersen dort sie ist normalerweise
arbeitet sie von London aus jetzt hat
sie den König begleitet hallo Helke
hallo grüß Dich also wir haben es gerade
gehört Charles war schon öfter in
Deutschland das letzte Mal 2020 aber
eben als Prinz nicht als König welche
Bedeutung wird diesen Besuch jetzt bei
gemessen
ja es gibt so ein bisschen zwei Ironien
an dem heutigen Tag also erstmal ist es
ja so ein zufälliger erster Besuch muss
man mal sagen liegt an der Absage haben
wir eben im Stück noch mal gehört das
Frankreich besucht und der zweite
Umstand ist ja der dass
dies eine seine erste Deutschlandreise
so ein bisschen die Kontinuität dessen
was seine Mutter in den Jahren zuvor an
deutschen Beziehungen gelebt hat denn
ihre letzte Reise ging auch nach
Deutschland tatsächlich und noch eine
andere Sache an diesem Tag ist ja
eigentlich ganz
bemerkenswert genau vor sechs Jahren an
diesem Tag hat nämlich Großbritannien
das Austritt gesucht aus der EU
eingereicht also das wird sehr
symbolhaft sein und sicherlich überall
wo immer er wen trifft auf Politik
trifft und es tut dann morgen vor allen
Dingen im Bundestag sehr sicher
thematisieren wird in irgendeiner Weise
und dieser Empfang am Brandenburger Tor
den wir gleich erleben werden den hat es
ja in dieser Form noch nicht gegeben
ja das stimmt Ehrenformation und
Nationalhymne werden wir jetzt hier
gleich erleben und überhaupt ist das ein
Besuch der mehrere erste Maler hat denn
es hat auch noch nie ein gekröntes
Staatsoberhaupt im Bundestag gesprochen
so wie morgen also es wird viele
Höhepunkte geben und zu besprechen geben
und wenn Charles jetzt gleich ankommt
was werden wir dann genau sehen was
sieht das Protokoll vor
das Protokoll sieht vor ihren Formation
und Nationalhymne sie schreiten dann die
rein hier ab und anschließend ist dann
gedacht dies ist sozusagen der Ort der
einzige im Programm hier in Berlin
jedenfalls später in Hamburg wird es das
auch noch mal geben wo Camilla und
Charles auf Menschen treffen und mit
Menschen reden das ist hier geplant die
stehen hier überall hinter uns da sind
ungefähr ich glaube mehrere hundert
zugelassen und die werden die Chance
haben mit den beiden zu sprechen hier
und aktuelle Informationen rund um den
Besuch von König Charles bekommen wir
auch auf unserem Instagram Kanal ZDF
Royal das nur normal als Hintergrundinfo
da gibt's nämlich auch einen Liveticker
so ähm solange der König noch nicht da
ist lass uns über seinen
Selbstverständnis sprechen denn im
Grunde genommen will Charles ja sehr
viel mehr sein als in Anführungszeichen
nur ein König er gilt ja auch als sehr
politisch in welchem Spannungsfeld
bewegt er sich da
ja ich glaube er will unbedingt ein
König sein denn ich meine die Welt hat
beobachtet dass er der König ist jetzt
der am längsten darauf gewartet hat
viele viele Dekaden als Prinz von Wales
und ja diese Spannungsfeld ist dass der
Rolle des Monarchen das
Neutralitätsgebot verordnet ist er hat
nun politisch gewirkt durch all diese
ganzen Jahrzehnte weil er sich eben
schon sehr früh um zu Umweltfragen zum
Klimaschutz geäußert hat öffentlich das
erste Mal in einer Rede als er 21 war
und alle fragen sich jetzt natürlich so
ein bisschen wie kann er das Fortsetzen
es ist aber so dass er in seiner ersten
Rede als König schon gesagt hat es wird
mir nicht länger möglich sein so viel
Zeit und so viel Energie in die Themen
zu setzen die mir am Herzen liegen das
sind diese Themen Umweltschutz
Klimawandel und wie man ihn bekämpft
und das haben natürlich alle als eine
Botschaft
gedeutet dass er dieses
Neutralitätsgebot wird ernst nehmen
müssen und deshalb natürlich nur so weit
politisch ist wie er bisher Spuren
gelegt hat es gab zum Beispiel ja auch
diesen Moment das war die Klimakonferenz
in Ägypten der britische Premiere hatte
dann bekannt gegeben er würde dort nicht
hinreisen
und dann gab es so ein bisschen so ein
warte Moment kommentiert das in
irgendeiner Weise der König das tat er
nicht also ich glaube man kann unterm
Strich relativ klar sagen er ist ein
Monarch der ganz klar diese Interessen
hat und da auch nicht nur geredet hat
sondern auch getan hat mit vielen
Modellprojekten die er auch über seine
Stiftung finanziert hat
aber er ist ein neutraler König so wie
es immer war
das ist gerade gesagt Klimaschutz
Nachhaltigkeit das sind seine großen
Themen da dürfte einen Besuch in einem
Land in dem eine Partei mit Schwerpunkt
Umweltpolitik ja Teil der Regierung ist
für ihn noch möglicherweise besonders
interessant sein
ja da gibt es ja ein Treffen heute im
Schloss Bellevue dem Amtssitz des
Bundespräsidenten das unter dieses Thema
tatsächlich gestellt ist
Charles ist auch jemand der seit langem
Jahren seit vielen Dekaden seit 30
Jahren sagt er selber immer wieder Rat
gesucht hat bei
deutschen Spezialisten zu Ökolandbau
ja also dieses Thema wird sozusagen die
ganzen Konversationen sicherlich durch
Ziehen und
die Experten seit der König ist das sind
jetzt gut sechs Monate haben sich
intensiv damit beschäftigt wie weit er
das wird weiter leben können und man
muss sich natürlich auch Fragen als
Prinz von Wales für all seine Stiftung
Wohltätigkeit und auch solche die dem
die dem Umweltschutz am Umweltschutz
Arbeiten wird er weiter Spenden
einwerfen können ich glaube das könnte
als König ein bisschen schwieriger sein
als als Thronfolger
wie würdest du jetzt allgemein das
Verhältnis von Charles zu Deutschland
beschreiben
das ist glaube ich sehr eng er ist 40
Mal in Deutschland gewesen
das erste Mal mit als Teenager ich
glaube mit 16 auf Verwandten Besuch sie
haben ja viele Verwandte hier in
Deutschland tatsächlich und er wird auch
Cousinen und Cousins bei diesem
abendlichen Bankett hier heute treffen
er soll so ein bisschen bedauert haben
dass er das ist ich glaube sein Onkel
Max von Baden der im vergangenen
Dezember gestorben ist da hatte er den
Wunsch dorthin zu reisen zu Beerdigung
aber das kannst du als König natürlich
nicht einfach machen noch dazu wenn dann
dem nächsten Staatsbesuch ansteht also
das fiel aus aber dessen Nachfahren
trifft er dann heute hier offenbar in
Berlin
und ähm ja seine Bande sind insofern eng
als er immer auch diesen Austausch
gesucht hat ich habe es eben gesagt mit
Spezialisten von Ökolandbau und er
spricht deutsch die Meinung gehen ein
bisschen auseinander wie gut wirklich
die einen sagen sehr gut die anderen
sagen nicht so fließen auf jeden Fall
diese Rede 2020 im Bundestag Klang
danach dass er Deutsch spricht und er
wird das auch morgen wieder zeigen
wir schauen mal noch mal gerade ans
Brandenburger Tor wo du auch stehst noch
sind Charles und Camilla nicht
angekommen das kann jetzt jeden Moment
so weit sein lass uns so lange noch mal
in den Chat schauen mehr da in der
Community sind die Meinung so ein
bisschen gespalten also da schreibt zum
Beispiel einen User Deutschland würde
eine konstitutionelle Monarchie
ebenfalls gut stehen schon allein als
moralische Instanz
die Barbara schreibt danke ZDF für den
Livestream ja sehr gerne immer wieder
und es gibt aber auch durchaus Kritik ne
ähm was das alles wieder kostet so ein
Aufriss wegen einem Besuch die Kosten
ist das etwas was im Vorfeld in der
Kritik war
Fakten da eigentlich aus Großbritannien
zu berichten einmal wenn man auf die
Umfragen schaut also wenn die Menschen
gefragt werden ist eine Monarchie weiter
das richtige dann sagt die Mehrheit
jetzt ja guckt man auf die
Zustimmungswerte für Charles sind sie
jetzt höher als sie im Mai 2022 waren
als er noch Prinz Charles war und es
gibt in Großbritannien seit langem
Jahren ja
Initiativen die für eine Republik werben
die Initiative Republic die von sich
selber sagen sie haben 120.000
Mitglieder ob das so ist man weiß es
nicht die jedenfalls haben jetzt vor
nach diesem monarchenwechsel
überall aufzutreten wo Charles ist und
laut not my King zu rufen das haben wir
jetzt gerade neulich vor westmonster
Abbey am Commonwealth day gesehen
die sind wollen massiv auftreten und ähm
insgesamt wird aber gesagt sie hätten
keine so wahnsinnig große Bedeutung eben
vor dem Hintergrund dieser Umfragen
unterschiedlicher Institute die klar
diese Monarchie der Monarchie weiter
Rückhalt geben
Olivia schreibt wichtig ist gute
Beziehungen auch nach dem Austritt der
EU zu Großbritannien zu haben
Stichwort brexit da gibt es durchaus
eine gewisse Entfremdung das kann man
nicht weg reden wie wird sich das aus
ja brexit da ist ja sozusagen eigentlich
die ungefragte Frage wie hat sich
eigentlich das Königshaus wie vielleicht
die einzelnen Mitglieder zum brexit
gestellt seiner Zeit bei der
austrittsfrage
insgesamt wird Charles als Europäer
gesehen das spricht er so nicht aus aber
alle die die Rede die er hier im
Bundestag im November 2020 gehalten hat
werten das so oder man kann das so
interpretieren er hat damals einen
Dichter zitiert
und hat die Zeile zitiert no man is
really an Island und hat das dann
niemand ist wirklich eine Insel und hat
das sozusagen dann einen Vergleich zu
Ländern gezogen und hat gesagt
gemeinsam ist besser als allein mit
Blick auf den brexit der war da
durchgesickert und umgesetzt in
Großbritannien
haben das dann alle die das beobachtet
haben so interpretiert dass er Erde
europäischen Seite zu neigt er hat auch
z.B 2018 im EU-Parlament von Straßburg
betont dass der Kampf gegen den
Klimawandel der eine so große Aufgabe
ist dass der nicht alleine zu machen sei
sondern nur in europäischen
verbünden sozusagen also ähm unterm
Strich bei allem was er sagen darf
politisch in diese Richtung haben immer
alle
interpretiert dass er auf der
europäischen Seite steht und wir sehen
dass jetzt die Wagenkolonne mit den
Limousinen ankommt ich denke wir schauen
uns das kurz an denn gleich müssten
Charles und Camilla aus dem Wagen
aussteigen
hier sehen wir zuerst Bundespräsident
Steinmeier und seine Frau Elke
bühnenkova in rot
winken in die Menge
güdebänder Entschuldigung
und wir warten auf Charles und Camilla
ja winken in die Menge und jetzt müssten
müsste das
kann auch schnell was schief gehen jetzt
müsste das Königspaar gleich
vom Bundespräsidenten begrüßt werden
wir schauen uns das zusammen an
[Musik]
[Applaus]
so Hilke während wir warten vielleicht
kurz die Frage wie erlebst du die
Stimmung jetzt vor Ort am Brandenburger
Tor
die Leute sind wie soll ich sagen
so ein bisschen Verhalten gucken
es gibt ja nein danke ich würde ich
nicht sagen gibt auch Menschen die mit
Hüten da sind tatsächlich das finde ich
jetzt ganz besonders erstaunlich habe
sogar unter den Reportern eine gesehen
ich weiß nicht ob es eine dritte ist
ja und gucken gespannt und jetzt fehlt
ja sozusagen noch das gar nichts paar
das fehlt und darauf warten wir auch
einigermaßen gespannt wir bleiben mal
weiter drauf
wenn man wüsste gerne was da jetzt noch
besprochen wird ob da jetzt zum
möglicherweise letzte Details zum
Protokoll zum zum Besuch besprochen
werden damals leider kein Mikro in der
Nähe
ich glaube das ist alles sowas von
besprochen
also ganz ganz sicher
ringsrum auf den Dächern gibt es Kameras
und Sicherheitspersonal also dieser
ganze Bereich ihr habt das Vorhinein
Eingangs der Sendung mit jetzt Schneider
besprochen sowas von abgesichert da
niemandem entgeht hier irgendwas und
jetzt fahren aber
Autos vor die vermutlich die sind auf
die wir warten ich kann es nicht so ganz
sehen von hier aus wir sehen die Autos
bis auf eines die fahren aber alle
wieder weg jetzt kommt eine neue Polizei
Kolonne
warum
die wir uns noch nicht
immerhin das Wetter scheint mitzumachen
in Berlin
das war in den letzten Tagen in der
Hauptstadt nicht immer so da gab es auch
üble Regenstürme insofern ja das ist
schon mal von Vorteil es ist faires es
ist faires Wetter tatsächlich und
ganz still ist es auf dem Platz jenseits
von dieser Polizei Eskorte die wir jetzt
hier sehen und deswegen glaube ich
könnte es jetzt ernst werden tatsächlich
Wagen vor
mehrere
hier sehen wir Charles und Camilla
und wir lernen sie gehen nicht zu Fuß
noch so ein Stückchen wie das
bundespräsidentenpaar sondern sie werden
direkt vorgefahren sie werden direkt
vorgefahren und soweit ich das alleine
sehen kann auch in einem britischen
Modell
so und dies ist jetzt aber der lauteste
Jubel ich bin seither verfolgt haben
ja und tatsächlich erleben wir hier
gerade einen historischen Moment diesen
Empfang am Brandenburger Tor des
britischen Königspaares was hat es so
eben noch nicht gegeben
ja wir sehen wie er König Charles und
Bundespräsident Steinmeier sowie Camilla
und Elke Büdenbender sich begrüßen
möglicherweise ein wenig Smalltalk
halten
und was steht jetzt als nächstes im
Protokoll Hilfe
es geht von hier aus ins Schloss
Bellevue wir sprachen anfangs drüber das
ist dann die Veranstaltung wo ist
tatsächlich auch Umweltfragen und so
etwas geht und es wird heute Abend dort
ein Bankett geben
ausgewählte Gäste Verwandte aus
Deutschland sind da eingeladen
und dann geht es ja morgen weiter wollen
wir auf das Programm von morgen auch
schon mal gucken können wir gerne machen
klar mit der Rede im Bundestag nämlich
am Mittag vorher besucht er
einen Wochenmarkt den wittenberg-markt
hier in Berlin und
den Tag beginnt er im Kanzleramt um sich
mit dem Bundeskanzler kurz zu treffen
das ist für morgen angesetzt und dann
geht die Reise weiter nach Brandenburg
morgen
sie werden das Ökodorf Brodowin besuchen
das ist so ein Ja ich sag mal
ganzheitliches
ökoland-projekt
Anfang der 90er Jahre aus einer LPG
entstanden die sich eben nicht nur um
Ökolandbau da verdient gemacht haben
oder daran gearbeitet haben sondern sich
auch darum kümmern dass die Menschen da
Arbeit finden 100 Arbeitsplätze immerhin
hat das solche Projekte interessieren
auch diesen König
und was steht jetzt hier direkt am
Brandenburger Tor noch an
[Musik]
Ehrenformation ich bin jetzt leider
nicht so eine militärische Expertin ich
glaube aber das bedeutet abschreiten
dieser
Formation die hier
aufmarschiert ist
und welche Grußworte es gibt hören wir
gleich denke ich absolut soll noch ein
Gruppenbild stattfinden möglicherweise
ist das jetzt schon passiert
und
dann hieß es zumindest dass Charles und
Camilla quasi noch mit den Menschen am
Brandenburger Tor sprechen wollen
das werden wir dann auch gleich sehen
das ist hier der Ort in das ist hier der
Ort in Berlin in dem sie in Kontakt
kommen mit Menschen und zwar auch der
einzige organisierte Ort in dem sie in
Kontakt kommen in Hamburg wird es das
dann noch mal geben denn am Freitag
werden sie ja auch noch in Hamburg sein
mit einem Programm was ich auch ganz
viel mit Umweltprojekten Hafenausbau und
sowas beschäftigen wird auch da werden
sie Kontakt mit Menschen haben und es
wird auch eine Party geben tatsächlich
und jetzt sehen wir eben diese
Ehrenformation
[Musik]
so werden gesehen wie König Charles eben
mit militärischen Ehren empfangen wurde
die
ehrenformationen abgelaufen ist
abgeschritten ist gemeinsam mit
Bundespräsident Steinmeier und sich
jetzt eben wenn man so will unters Volk
mischt
Hilde Frage an dich ist das ein König
der großen Wert darauf legt mit den
Menschen ins Gespräch zu kommen
ich würde das so bewerten ja also wenn
man so verfolgt was ich her tue
was für Termine er so hat dann ist das
so er geht in ganz unterschiedliche
Communitys versucht in multinationalen
Communitys unterwegs zu sein um
sozusagen die offene britische
Gesellschaft zu unterstützen ja er ist
ein Mensch der nah ran geht das
unterscheidet ihn von seiner Mutter auch
muss man sagen die ja eine sehr gemochte
Monarchen war tatsächlich mit
sensationellen Zustimmungswerten
aber er das ist sehr auffällig geht na
ran an die Menschen und kürzlich zum
Beispiel ist er gewesen in einem
Stadtteil in einem Bezirk in London der
sehr multi-national ist und zwar
wahnsinnig Menschen auf der Straße also
die Menschen interessieren sich für ihn
er ist in dieser Rolle glaubwürdig
als Prinz galt er ja eher nicht als
besonders
volksnah lag das damals an Diana deren
Beliebtheitswerte halt einfach und
schlagbar waren dass er aus diesem
Schatten nicht herauskam was hat sich
geändert
ja da ist er natürlich so wie sie auch
nehme ich mal an so nach menschlichem
durch ein tiefes Tal gegangen und
tatsächlich seine Beziehung zu Camilla
damals war
für die Menschen
weil eben er sozusagen gefühlt damit die
Prinzessin der Herzen am Ende auf dem
Gewissen hatte sage ich mal so ein
bisschen hart so ist es gesehen worden
in Teilen von Großbritanniens
Gesellschaft
ja da hat er hat seine Beliebtheit
massiv drunter gelitten das muss man
sagen und er hat aber irgendwie
hingekriegt
wahrscheinlich mit Palast PRR diese
Reputation wieder herzustellen und wenn
wir über die Frauen reden auch Camilla
natürlich weil Camilla war natürlich in
Teilen mal irgendwann die meist gehasste
Frau im Land
zum Zeitpunkt des Todes von Prinzessin
Diana
und sie verhält sich aber
alle sagen so unauffällig und so
wie soll ich sagen anpassungsfähig das
auch ihre Beliebtheitswerte fair sind
und das inzwischen irgendwie alles geht
und wer hätte gedacht in diesen Jahren
damals dass sie demnächst an der Seite
dieses Königs gekrönt wird denn auch sie
wird ja tatsächlich gekrönt also das ist
eine echte pr-meisterleistung des
Palasts würde ich mal sagen und das war
ja auch ein absolut langer Weg ja wir
sehen die Bilder hier der König Charles
Präsident Steinmeier auch Camilla sie
sprechen mit den Leuten Stimmung wirkt
einigermaßen gelöst kann man sagen
durchaus so würde ich das sehen auf die
Entfernung hier glaube die Menschen
freuen sich also ich meine die hierher
gekommen sind in jedem Fall freuen sich
hier teil zu haben und mit den beiden zu
reden nehme ich doch mal ganz schwer an
den Eindruck macht ist und so ziehen sie
jetzt entlang dieser
weiß-rotensitter ihre Runde ich bin
nicht so richtig im Bilde wie lange sie
das jetzt tun dürfen aber die Polizei
wird das Wissen und das sowas von unter
Kontrolle haben
ja und die Blümchen werden gleich
weitergereicht es werden selfies gemacht
das werden viele viele Hände geschüttelt
die Bilder kennt man gar nicht mehr so
seit Corona insofern ja ja hier mit
Hüten du sagtest es viele immer mal
wieder sieht man diese britischen Hüte
sehr schön Fascinator habe ich vorhin
auch schon gesehen also könnte ich
Charles quasi auf Tuchfühlung mit dem
Volk vielleicht hier noch eine Frage aus
dem Chat ähm Christian möchte gerne
wissen warum ist denn überhaupt diese
militärischen Ehren gab
ich würde gerne noch eben zum Stichwort
Hände schütteln eins sagen die Queen
löste ja solche
Situationen durch das Tragen von
Handschuhen das ist als Mann natürlich
ein bisschen seltsam und nicht üblich
deswegen kann er das sicherlich nicht
machen sie machte das eigentlich immer
wieso Ehrenformation und militärische
ehren
um zu unterstreichen dass das
Deutschland wichtig ist dazu ist
eigentlich diese militärische
Vorstellung nächstes mal gedacht und ich
bin auch ganz froh dass ich vorhin
nichts Falsches angekündigt habe und
dass sie das tatsächlich abgeschritten
sind wie es vorher gesagt habe absolut
und vielen Dank auch für deinen Hinweis
Silke mit den Handschuhen die hat jetzt
kann man ganz genau erkennen dass auch
Camilla Handschuhe trägt die hat das
insofern auch wesentlich einfacher ja
Prinzessin von Diana von Baden schreibt
auf Youtube äh willkommen in Deutschland
König Charles Barbara schreibt bin schon
ganz unruhig
negative Stimmen gibt's natürlich auch
muss man den kennen peinliche
Veranstaltung so hat halt jeder seine
Meinung dazu
geschenke gibt's auch wie wir gerade
sehen ist das vielleicht auch so ein
bisschen
Sicherheitsrisiko oder sind die Leute
die jetzt in diesem Bereich sind so gut
durchgecheckt dass es
Sicherheitspersonal da einigermaßen
entspannt sein kann
darum gehe ich jetzt mal aus denn
Sicherheits Erwägung werden ja im
Vorfeld solcher Staatsbesuche
ganz massiv gemacht wie wir gesehen
haben mit der Absage des französischen
Besuchs denn der ist vor allen Dingen
wegen Sicherheitsbedenken dann abgesagt
worden natürlich auch wegen der Stimmung
weil man es jetzt nicht für so
angemessen hielt nachdem
Präsident macron überall als König
Ludwig der XIV abgebildet war der wie
ein König einfach durchgesetzt hatte
dass das Rentenalter von 62 auf 64
raufgesetzt wurde was ja der Auslöser
ist für diese massiven Proteste in Paris
in Bordeaux beides Stationen die
eigentlich im Visier waren für diesen
französischen Staatsbesuch aber nun fand
man es nicht so elegant dann einen
echten König für den ein Bankett in
versail zu geben und man hatte auch
echte Sicherheitsbedenken tatsächlich
also das war der Grund warum der Besuch
dort abgesagt worden ist und wir
Deutschland das erste Land sind das Ziel
seines ersten Staatsbesuches ist
und der Empfang ist durchaus positiv man
hat auch den Eindruck dass das
Königspaar sich jetzt auch durchaus Zeit
nimmt also das ist nicht irgendwie kurz
vor Schluss Ende schütteln ist sondern
dass sie wirklich auch versuchen ins
Gespräch zu kommen was natürlich auch
schöne Bilder produziert
das ist so wenn wir noch darüber
sprechen weil ich es gerade von hier aus
sehe er wird begleitet vom britischen
Außenminister James kleverly den ich da
in der Menge auch stehen sehe
ja dann üblich ist ja
sozusagen so eine es gibt schon ein paar
Begleiter es ist nicht so dass da so
eine Wirtschaftsdelegation wie wir das
von Reisenden Politikern Politikern
kennen ähm also so eine Gruppe von
Botschaftern und eben James clever Lady
nicht da stehen sehe ja
solange der König noch Hände lass uns
vielleicht noch mal auf weitere
Programmpunkte schauen morgen spricht
königschals im Bundestag vor dem
Parlament ist schon bekannt über welches
Thema er sprechen wird
nee das ist im Vorfeld nicht bekannt da
kann ich noch mal Anknüpfen an den
Außenminister aus dem Außenministerium
kommt eigentlich eine solche Rede man
muss sich nicht vorstellen dass der
König selber in Winzer oder Buckingham
oder sonst wo sitzt und sie schreibt
sondern sie wird in Abstimmung mit ihm
und mit seinem Privatsekretär
geschrieben
und sie wird vorher üblicherweise nicht
veröffentlicht habe ich gelernt so dass
wir einfach werden hinhören müssen ja
um zu wissen was die Themen sind aber
wir haben davon ja schon viele gestreift
ja und dann möchte ich mich an dieser
Stelle ganz herzlich bei Dir bedanken
ZDF London course von den tin am Helke
Petersen du wirst natürlich diesen
Besuch das König Charles weiter für uns
begleiten vielen Dank
tschüss
und damit gehen wir dann direkt weiter
vors Schloss Bellevue dass er die
nächste Station des Königspaar sein wird
zu ZDF Königshaus Expertin Julia Melcher
hallo
Julia freue mich sehr dass du Zeit für
uns hast ähm wie hast du die Ankunft des
Königspaars bis jetzt erlebt wie würdest
du das bewerten
ja leider nur aus der Ferne denn ich
stehe halt hier am Schloss Bellevue das
ist der nächste Programmpunkt des
Staatsbesuches hier am Amtssitz des
Bundespräsidenten was eigentlich
normalerweise der Schauplatz ist für die
militärischen Ehren wenn dein
Staatsoberhaupt in Berlin willkommen
geheißen wird dann findet das hier statt
es ist halt das allererste Mal überhaupt
dass das am Brandenburger Tor
stattgefunden hat und das ist halt auch
ein Zeichen dass der König also hier
auch mit besonderen Ehren empfangen wird
dass dieses also auch historisch als ein
besonderer Staatsbesuch einzuordnen ist
und wir sehen hier Camilla und die Frau
des Bundespräsidenten wovon ich ausgehe
dass sie jetzt so demnächst sich auch
mal wieder ins Auto setzen werden und
eben zu dir dann weiterfahren wenn er
sie jetzt nicht zu Dir persönlich leider
aber sich auf den Weg zum Schloss
Bellevue machen muss dann weitergeht was
steht dann genau auf dem Programm
also wir werden gleich hinter mir
erleben dass der deutsche
Bundespräsident mit Frau Büdenbender und
der britische König mit Königin Camilla
hier auf der Treppe posieren werden für
ein Foto und dann geht es erstmal rein
der König wird sich in das Gästebuch
eintragen es werden dann hinter
verschlossenen Türen staatsgeschenke
ausgetauscht das gehört also auch zu
seinem Staatsbesuch dazu
es werden Orden verlieren davon können
wir ausgehen denn das ist üblich also
für persönliche Persönlichkeiten einen
Orden zu verleihen und unter
Staatsoberhaupt Baden wird das also
gemacht sobald es das erste Mal ist und
dass es heute das erste Mal das
Bundespräsident Steinmeier Empfang an
einen britischen König zum empfängt und
es ist das erste Mal für König Charles
also wir rechnen damit das beide sich
gegenseitig einen Orden verleihen werden
und im Anschluss gibt es hier heute
Nachmittag Klima Gespräche also es ist
eine Gesprächsrunde die der
Bundespräsident ins Leben gerufen hat
heute
dem König zu informieren über den
Entwicklungsstand der Energiewende in
Deutschland über die Nachhaltigkeit über
das Engagement auf deutscher Seite denn
der König das wissen wir alle er gilt
als der grüne König er ist ein eine
Autorität auf dem Gebiet des
Klimaschutzes und ihm wird also heute
präsentiert was der Stand der Dinge in
Deutschland ist und hinter mir ist also
auch gerade schon am Schloss Bellevue
der Bundeswirtschaftsminister
eingetroffen und die Außenministerin
Anna-Lena baerbock also es wird eine
interessante Runde hier gleich geben und
wir sehen dass das Königspaar sich jetzt
im Auto wieder in Bewegung gesetzt hat
also einen Haken an den Programmpunkt
Brandenburger Tor machen kann und eben
auf dem Weg zum Schloss Bellevue ist das
heißt wir haben jetzt einen Moment Zeit
und können auf das weitere Programm in
den nächsten zwei Tagen schauen das hat
anfangs zusammengefasst
2 € Fighter für den König Charles wird
in Berlin mit militärischen Ehren
empfangen inklusive Salutschüsse
vom Flughafen BER geht's zum
Brandenburger Tor dort wartet
Bundespräsident Steinmeier und lädt ein
heute Abend zum staatsbank-kit im
Schloss Bellevue
morgen empfängt dann Olaf Scholz den
König im Kanzleramt mit Spannung
erwartet wird die Rede von Charles im
Bundestag die dann auf dem Programm
steht er wird sie teilweise auf Deutsch
halten heißt es aus Berlin seine
verstorbene Mutter die Queen hat
übrigens nie vor dem Bundestag
gesprochen nach zwei Tagen Berlin geht
es dann weiter nach Hamburg in die St
nikolai Kirche dort will Charles den
Opfern des Zweiten Weltkriegs gedenken
ist ZDF Königshaus Expertin Julia
Melcher die uns exklusive Einblicke und
Einschätzungen geben wird wir sehen auch
dass die Autokolonne sich jetzt in
Bewegung gesetzt hat allzu weit weg ist
der Weg ja nicht zum Schloss Bellevue
Julia Charles zum ersten Mal als König
in Deutschland da erleben und haben wir
bereits die ein oder andere Premiere
erlebt welche werden das sein
eine große Premiere ist das
normalerweise eine der Opfer des Zweiten
Weltkrieges gedacht wird hier an der
neuen Wache in Berlin das ist eigentlich
so der Programmpunkt militärische Ehren
halt am Schloss Bellevue und dann im
Laufe des ersten Tages des
Staatsbesuches geht es dann zum
Brandenburger Tor und zum zur neuen
Wache um dort den Kranz niederzulegen
und diesen Programmpunkt gibt es nicht
sondern in Hamburg wird der Opfer des
Zweiten Weltkrieges gedacht aber
Opfer die durch britische Bomben
gelitten haben und das ist eine große
Neuerung deshalb ist noch nie gegeben
also es wird morgen in der am Freitag an
der am St Nikolai an dem ST Nikolai
Mahnmal der Opfer des Zweiten
Weltkrieges gedacht die durch britische
und amerikanische Bomben in der
Bombennacht von Hamburg gestorben sind
und das ist doch ein großer Schritt denn
es ist die Anerkennung von Schuld und
Leid auf beiden Seiten es gibt auch
zusätzlich noch einen anderen
Programmpunkt in Hamburg Dammtor wo
einem Andreas Denkmal besucht wird für
einen Kindertransport von jüdischen
Kindern im Jahr 1938 die in
Großbritannien Zuflucht bekommen haben
und es ist also ein sagen wir so ein
sehr
emotionaler Programmpunkt vor allen
Dingen in Hamburg hier in Berlin ist der
Fokus mehr auf dem Thema Umwelt und
Nachhaltigkeit und natürlich ganz
besonders und ich glaube das ist das
große Thema dieses Staatsbesuches die
Einheit zu demonstrieren in Zeiten des
russischen angriffskriegs gegen die
Ukraine denn wir sehen auch heute
Nachmittag zum Beispiel morgen
nachmittag Entschuldigung dass der nein
ich glaube das ist doch heute nein
morgen Nachmittag ist richtig dass der
König und der Bundespräsident ein
deutsch-britisches
Pionierbataillon besuchen werden das ist
das Einzige die einzige gemeinsame
militärische Einheit die es gibt die
stationiert normalerweise in Minden und
die präsentieren also morgen hier in
Brandenburg eine Wasserbrücke einem eine
mobile Wasserbrücke die aufgebaut wird
also es geht schon darum auch und darum
halt auch diese große sym Bolik des
Brandenburger Tors heute die Einheit zu
demonstrieren in dieser schwierigen Zeit
dass der Westen
zusammenhält und es ist man darf es auch
nicht nur als Staatsbesuch in
Deutschland werden sondern eigentlich
hätte ja noch der Staatsbesuch in
Frankreich zuvor stattgefunden also ist
das große Signal ist eigentlich nach dem
brexit das Großbritannien und die
Europäische Union den Einheit
demonstrieren möchten
du sagst das absolut also da stecken ja
große politische und gesellschaftliche
Themen unserer Zeit drin die jetzt in
diesem Besuch quasi verarbeitet werden
gleichzeitig heißt es ja immer dass der
britische König neutral sein soll ist
das nicht doch am Ende ein sehr sehr
politischer Besuch durch die Symbolik
also im Prinzip ist das der Staat hier
auf Reisen hier neben mir fährt auch
jetzt gerade die Kolonne vor dem Schloss
Bellevue vor mit dem Bundespräsidenten
Bänder und König Charles dem dritten und
Königin Camilla und mit ihnen aber eine
große Delegation aus der Politik der
Außenminister von Großbritannien ist
dabei Vertreter aus der Wirtschaft aus
Wissenschaft
Umweltthemen spielt natürlich eine große
Rolle und man sieht also es ist nur er
ist der personifizierte Staat und
natürlich findet diese Reise statt auf
Ersuchen der Regierung es ist nicht sein
Wunsch gewesen aber es ist ihm ein
großes Anliegen und wir sehen dass eben
die Gastgeber Bundespräsident Steinmeier
und seine Frau Elke Büdenbender jetzt
vorgefahren sind sie sind bereits aus
dem Auto ausgestiegen und sie erwarten
jetzt das britische
Königspaar auf Schloss Bellevue Julia
was passiert jetzt im Schloss Bellevue
wenn das Königspaar angekommen ist
also das sind jetzt dann die ganz
normalen Schritte bei einem Staatsbesuch
die nach internationalen diplomatischen
diplomatischen Protokoll laufen der
König und die Königin werden hier gleich
Vorfahren und vom Bundespräsidenten und
Frau Büdenbender im Schloss Bellevue dem
Amtssitz des Bundespräsidenten
willkommen geheißen und man zieht sich
dann halt auch für einen kurzen Moment
zurück der König wird sich in das
goldene Buch eintragen der König und der
Bundespräsident werden Geschenke
austauschen manchmal ist es auch so bei
Staatsbesuchen dass man sich also auch
Exponate aus den Sammlungen zeigt also
es gibt auch Kunstsammlungen alte
Geschenke die man sich schon bei
vergangenen Staatsbesuchen gegenseitig
überreicht hat also das ist dann so eine
das ist ein viele Gesten die zu einem
Staatsbesuch dazu gehören und wie gesagt
wir rechnen damit dass der
Bundespräsident also auch heute die
Sonderstufe des großkreuzes an den neuen
König von Großbritannien verleihen wird
und so lange die beiden noch nicht
eingetroffen sind können wir vielleicht
noch mal ähm auf die politischen
Erwartungen an König Charles eingehen
denn obwohl ja er eigentlich neutral
sein muss gibt es durchaus diese
Erwartungen zum Beispiel Stichwort
brexit wie geht das zusammen
na ja also was heißt Erwartungen an
diesen König
er ist ein neutrales Staatsoberhaupt und
er hat auch von Anfang an vor
Amtsantritt gesagt und bei seiner ersten
Ansprache an die Nation dass er sich an
diese Neutralität unbedingt gebunden
fühlt aber er setzt Zeichen wir wissen
dass er ein Mensch ist der im den
europäischen Gedanken der europäische
Gedanke sehr wichtig ist er selbst
stammt aus einer der europäischen
Familien die es überhaupt gibt und er
setzt schon durchaus auch Zeichen in
denen ähm Mitteln die er hat also
Empfänge die ergibt im Buckingham Palast
setzen also auch damit setzt der
Anzeichen wenn er z.B eine bestimmte
Gruppe von Minderheiten jetzt direkt
nach seinem Amtsantritt in den Palast
eingeladen hat zu einer Zeit als gerade
im britischen Unterhaus diskutiert
worden ist über illegale Einwanderung
und da zeigt er wie wichtig ihm das
Thema Integration auch ist also er lebt
das Thema
Diversität durchaus und das ist ja auch
nur ein politisch sehr relevantes Thema
und das werden wir also auch bei diesem
Staatsbesuch erleben es gibt
Programmpunkte sie werden Flüchtlinge
besuchen
Königin Camilla die jetzt lade hier
Vorfahren wird auch eine weitere
Einrichtung besuchen ich glaube wir
werfen gleich erstmal wahrscheinlich
einen Blick jetzt hier auf die Eskorte
des britischen Königs ja das heißt dass
er mit von 45 Wagen begleitet wird also
es ist ein mords Aufruhr hier in Berlin
und den ersten Besuch der Queen gab es
ja
1965 würde mal sagen seitdem ist viel
passiert wie hat sich das Deutsch
britische Verhältnis seit dem entwickelt
also jeder Staatsbesuch eigentlich seit
1965 stand auch immer so unter einem
politischen Thema es ging natürlich um
die Versöhnung nach dem Zweiten
Weltkrieg 1965 und dann mit den
Besuchern 1978
1992 stand dann also auch mir erst sehr
kalte Krieg dann die Wiedervereinigung
im Vordergrund und bei den letzten
Staatsbesuchen 2024 und 2015 ging es um
Europa und jetzt nach dem brexit dieser
Staatsbesuch erst acht Jahre nach dem
letzten Staatsbesuch das ist eine sehr
hohe Frequenz das kennen wir sonst so
auch nicht ähm das ist doch ein großes
Zeichen für die Verbundenheit dass man
Deutsch
noch sehr nah zueinander Rücken und
Einheit demonstrieren wollen und
Geschlossenheit und jetzt fährt gerade
hier
die Kolonne des britischen Königs an mir
vorbei wir sehen gerade die
Staatskarosse mit der Standarte von
König Charles dem dritten
die Staatskarosse stammt aus dem
Fuhrpark des britischen Königshauses
die vorher hier angeliefert worden ist
und nun sehen wir den Moment das König
Charles III und seine Frau Königin
Camilla hier an den Stufen von Schloss
Bellevue vom Bundespräsidenten und
seiner Frau willkommen geheißen werden
gut diese aus Eskorte ist dann auch
schnell durch Berlin durchgekommen ist
auch kein Wunder weil die Straßen extra
gesperrt worden was passiert jetzt
direkt als nächstes also wir sehen jetzt
werden erstmal Fotos gemacht und dann
wir sehen den Moment des Familienfotos
sozusagen drinnen hat sich schon eine
ein Teil der der britischen und der
deutschen Delegation versammelt es wird
im Anschluss an den Austausch der
staatsgeschenke und der Orden wird es
den eine
klima-gespräch geben zu dem hat der
Bundespräsident eingeladen
Robert Robert Habeck habe ich gerade
schon von weitem gesehen Annalena
baerbock und es geht in erster Linie
darum dass in diesem Fall der König
informiert wird über den Stand der
Energiewende in Deutschland über die
Engagement in Sachen Nachhaltigkeit und
das Thema Nachhaltigkeit spielt halt
hier eine große Rolle bei diesem
Staatsbesuch neben zwei drei anderen
ganz wichtigen Punkten
wir können in der Zwischenzeit mal ganz
kurz in den Chat schauen da schreibt
Lissy Lopez sehr schön Chris WhatsApp
wirklich wenig Schaulustige das haben
wir vorhin gehört das lag auch so ein
bisschen an den Sicherheitsvorkehrungen
Robert schreibt jedenfalls ein netter
Kerl zu sein und auch noch mit deutschen
Migrationshintergrund Julia vielleicht
kannst du zu diesem deutschen
Migrationshintergrund von König Charles
Robert die nennt noch ein bisschen was
erzählen
ja von beiden Seiten also
mütterlicherseits das liegt schon ein
bisschen weiter zurück gibt es die
Wurzeln zum Haus Sachsen Coburg und
Gotha und zum Haus Hannover und
väterlichersalz über Prinz Philip sind
die Bande doch noch sehr viel näher und
werden auch bis heute gepflegt zu den
deutschen Fürstenhäusern Hohenlohe Baden
und Hessen also da gibt es auch
weiterhin einen regen Austausch zwischen
Charles und seinen deutschen Vettern und
einen Punkt der den gerade glaube ich
Lissi genannt hatte dass man doch nicht
so viele Schaulustige gesehen hat ich
lag sicherlich eine
Sicherheitsvorkehrung und das ist aber
auch einer der Gründe oder sagen was
einer der Besonderheiten dieses
Staatsbesuches Charles hat sich explizit
gewünscht das ist diese Begegnung mit
den Bürgern und Bürgerinnen gibt und das
ist nämlich auch etwas was ihn sehr
unterscheidet von seiner Mutter dass er
einen ein König ist zum Anfassen und das
haben wir eigentlich ab dem ersten
Moment erlebt nach dem Tod seiner Mutter
als er ausgestiegen ist vor dem
Buckingham Palast und die Trauernden mit
dem Handschlag begrüßt hat das waren
doch alles sehr persönliche Momente und
jetzt gibt es den Eintrag ins Gästebuch
und ja Julia wir können nur hoffen dass
der Füller so tut wir soll da gibt es ja
eine Geschichte zu
ja damit habe ich gerechnet dass das
kommentiert wird heute da spricht mich
auch jeder drauf an dieser Moment dass
er sehr dass das sein Temperament mit
ihm durchgegangen ist als er seine
Urkunde bei seiner Proklamation
unterschrieben hat der ist die Urkunde
der Tisch war zu klein und wenige Tage
später ist der Füller ausgelaufen er hat
Temperament aber ein ganz wichtiger
Punkt den wir dabei auch gelernt haben
ist die Rolle die Camilla dabei spielt
sie ist die Frau die ihn also auch
beruhigt dir dein unheimlich guten
Einfluss auf ihn und die beiden erreicht
einen Blickkontakt die verstehen sich
ich habe mich gefragt was man ohnehin
dass man also auch die Königin würdigen
muss Camilla die also unheimlich
gewachsen ist in den letzten 15 Jahren
18 Jahren seit der Hochzeit von der
meist gehassten Frau Großbritanniens zu
einer sehr respektierten und auch
akzeptierten Persönlichkeit sie ist ein
sehr angenehmer ein sehr bescheidener
Charakter sie ist ein sehr flüssiges
Mitglied der königlichen Familie und vor
zehn Jahren noch als ich einen Film
gemacht habe zum Thronjubiläum der Queen
da haben viele noch die Hände über den
Kopf zusammengeschlagen bei der
Vorstellung das Charles eines Tages
König werden könnte und das Bild hat
sich total geändert also zehn Jahre
später sind Charles und Camilla ein sehr
respektiertes
angesehenes Ehepaar weil sie sich
einfach diese Sympathien auch durch sehr
viel Fleiß erarbeitet haben und auch
durch weil sie Themen setzen die halt
vom großen Gespür für die
gesellschaftspolitischen und
identitätspolitischen Themen dieser Zeit
zeugen Camilla ist eine eine eine
ja fast eine Aktivistin im Kampf gegen
häusliche Gewalt und da setzt sie
wirklich Zeichen und insofern das sind
Punkte die von denen erfahren wir
eigentlich sehr wenig aber sie spielen
eine große Rolle auch bei der Akzeptanz
dieses Königspaares in Großbritannien
und jetzt sind die Kameras außen vor
aber wo wir gerade bei Camilla sind
lassen uns gerne mal über sie sprechen
welches Programm hat sie denn in den
nächsten Tagen
ja es ist das damen-programm was auch so
üblich ist natürlich darf das nicht das
Programm der Staatsoberhäupter in den
Schatten stellen also bei den meisten
Programmpunkten ist sie dabei die
anderen zwei drei Programmpunkte die Sie
also mit Frau Büdenbender alleine
unternimmt gelten den Themen Kultur aber
auch der mit einem Besuch in der
Komischen Oper oder auch dem Thema
Integration wenn Sie hier eine eine
Stadtmission besuchen wird in der
Menschen die ohne Heimat sind also
geflüchtete eine neue Heimat und auch
eine neue Aufgabe finden die hier wohnen
dann in an dieser Institution refugi und
ein Programmpunkt den ich besonders nett
finde persönlich ist in Hamburg sie
besucht eine Grundschule eine
deutschspritische Grundschule es geht
ihr also auch immer um das Thema Bildung
und Jugendarbeit und Literatur und sie
wird begleitet von Axel Schäffler jeder
der Vater oder Mutter ist in Deutschland
der wird in kennen das ist der Autor vom
und der Illustrator vom Grüffelo
ich ähm jetzt sind die Kameras ja außen
vor und du hast gesagt es werden Orden
ausgetauscht und es werden ja wohl jetzt
auch Geschenke übergeben und ich habe
gelernt dass man da sehr viel falsch
machen kann Geschenke können ein heikles
Thema sein also die Queen war ja wohl
2015 damals Nord im just als sie ein
Bild mit ihr auf einem blauen Pferd vom
damaligen Bundespräsidenten glaubt
bekommen hat also da kann man viel
falsch machen mit Geschenken
aber bei der Königin als Pferdenarren
muss man schon damit rechnen dass man da
also auch wirklich nicht zu weit oder so
von der Realität abschweifen darf mit
einem naiven Bild das also ein
hellblaues Pferd gezeigt hat da hat
damals bei ihrem Staatsbesuch ich glaube
1978 der damalige Bundespräsident schon
besser gelegen denn der hat ihr zwei
Pferde geschenkt aber das waren also
damals natürlich noch Größenordnung in
denen wir uns heute nicht mehr bewegen
was ist heute gibt im übrigen das wissen
wir nicht wir sehen jetzt ich glaube
jetzt werden sich also auch bestimmte
Exponate gezeigt nein wir sehen die
Bilder gerade von den Bundespräsident
dieses Pferd gezeigt geschenkt hat ja
aber ich rechne damit denn es gab eine
Information und ich hoffe das wird also
auch so sein dass dieses Mal ein
Geschenk sein wird ein Baum der
gepflanzt wird denn das würde mich nicht
wundern ich habe gehört es wird ein Baum
gepflanzt und ich könnte mir vorstellen
dass das Geschenk ist von König Charles
an den Bundespräsidenten ein Baum
pflanzen hier in dem Park von Schloss
Bellevue denn das ist eine der ganz
großen Initiativen für die König Charles
steht natürlich die Umwelt aber auch ähm
das Thema der Forstwirtschaft der
Nachhaltigkeit des Prinzip der
Nachhaltigkeit die also aus der
Forstwirtschaft kommt und und es gibt
eine wunderbare Initiative in
Großbritannien den Queen Screen Kennedy
also den den Grünen das grüne
Schutzschild und das ist eine Initiative
ein Jahr vor dem Platin Jubiläum der
Königin der Verstorbenen Königin wurden
also Bäume gepflanzt letztes Jahr beim
platinjubiläum waren es schon eine
Million Bäume und der Königin sollte
dann eine Karte überreicht werden jetzt
nach einem Jahr nach ihrem
platinjubiläum eine Weltkarte wo man
sieht wo all diese Bäume gepflanzt
worden sind die Karte wird es geben aber
die Königin gibt es leider nicht mehr
aber es würde natürlich absolut passen
da sich Charles ja auch tatsächlich als
grüner König wenn man so will versteht
Gisela schreibt auf Facebook die kann
sich nämlich auch noch an die Pferde
erinnern solange der König nicht wie
seine Mutter bei ihrem Deutschland
besucht ein Geschenk im Wert von 60 000
€ fordert damals war es ein Pferd ähm
Simon schreibt man sollte nicht die
Wirkung von Königshäusern heutzutage
unterschätzen aber es muss eben auch in
die Geschichte passen eleon schreibt
sehr schöne Zeremonie dem König wünsche
ich einen schönen angenehmen Aufenthalt
ja es heißt ja dass die qu een bei ihren
Deutschland besuchen immer unheimlich
viele Sonderwünsche hatte ähm hört man
das von Charles auch
das muss ich ehrlich zugeben das ist an
mir vorbeigegangen es gibt ja immer
diese mehr dass er sich die wie nennt
man diese Schnürsenkel bügeln lässt ja
hab das stimmt das weiß ich nicht und
ich kann es mir auch kaum vorstellen
dass jetzt hier jemand dabei ist um ihm
die Schnürsenkel zu zu bügeln also ich
glaube die Menschen erleben ihn
eigentlich als an vielen nahbareren
König als es bei der Queen der Fall war
und
er sucht die Menschen die Nähe zum Volk
und es gibt einen Unterschied schon also
morgen Nachmittag ist
der Kalender leer sozusagen also es wird
morgen nachmittag keinen weiteren
Programmpunkt dann geben die haben also
irrsinnig viel Programm ich sag mal du
bist ungefähr 17 Uhr morgen Nachmittag
aber es gibt morgen keine Gegeneinladung
das ist eigentlich sonst üblich bei
Staatsbesuchen der erste Abend lädt der
Gastgeber einen der zweite Abend der
Gast und das findet in diesem Fall nicht
statt denn man muss auch sich überlegen
dieses Königspaar ist halt auch Mitte 70
und man kann von denen nicht erwarten
dass sie halt diese Taktung haben wie
das jetzt bei
anderen Staatsgästen ist die die sich in
ihren 50ern befinden also es wird auch
schon ein bisschen Rücksicht genommen
dass das Programm nicht so intensiv ist
zum eigentlich war ja auch davon
auszugehen dass die beiden schon einen
Staatsbesuch in Frankreich hinter sich
haben es wird eine Gegeneinladung geben
die findet dann in Hamburg statt dass
der letzte Programmpunkt in Hamburg am
Freitagnachmittag und das ist wird also
als Party deklariert wo also auch eine
Beatles Coverband auftreten wird und der
Teilnehmer vom der deutsche Teilnehmer
vom Eurovision Song Contest und da wird
auf Einladung der britischen Botschaft
werden dann Charles und Camilla
britische Bürger begrüßen und andere
Vertreter und das wird dann also eine
größere Party am Freitag Nachmittag in
Hamburg sein
wir könnten über noch so viele Themen
sprechen über Harry und Meghan über
Prinz Andrew über die bevorstehende
Krönung am 6 mai wir müssen jetzt
langsam zum Ende kommen vielleicht mit
einer letzten Frage zum Schluss die hat
Andreas gestellt
ja da hat ihm glaube ich die
Autokorrektur irgendwie ähm Streich
gespielt wird er schreibt der nimmt am
Staatsbank Rottweil im Schloss Bellevue
ich nehme mal ganz schwer an er meinte
Staatsbankett
ja das wüsste ich ehrlich gesagt auch
gerne ich kann halt nur ein paar
Schätzungen also ich kenne die Gäste
noch Liste noch nicht ein paar Personen
sind gesetzt das sind natürlich
Regierungsvertreter von beiden Seiten es
sind Mitglieder des Königshauses also
der König reißt ja auch hier an mit ich
sag mal den hohen Funktionieren des
Palastes die ja auch eine große Rolle
spielen in der Vermittlung zwischen
Königshaus und Regierung es werden
Vertreter sein deutsche Vertreter da
sein aus dem Bereichen Kunst Kultur
Wirtschaft es heißt dass die die Gründer
von biontech da sein werden es war auch
von Campino die Rede der Sänger von den
Toten Hosen er ist Deutscher und Brite
und also es wird also eine bunte
Mischung sein aber da muss ich mich
selber überraschen lassen wer da ist
okay und ähm darüber wirst Du uns morgen
berichten womit wir auch die Frage von
Barbara beantworten können berichtet
dass das ZDF morgen wieder live ja wir
sehen nicht morgen wieder als ZDF
Königshaus Expertin Julia Melchior live
ab 11 im ZDF Spezial zum Besuch von
König Charles ich sag schon mal vielen
Dank an dieser Stelle und die Sendung
wird dann moderiert von Christina von
unseren Sternberg die ja auch von ZDF
heute live kennt das war es von uns
schönen Nachmittag noch wie gesagt der
Hinweis es gibt auch ein instagram-kanal
ZDF oder real mit einem Liveticker da
verpasst ihr nichts